first get your ingredients to hand eggs  should be out of the fridge and at room  temperature soak saffron in warm water  saffron is the most expensive spice in  the world made from the dried stigma of  crocus flowers  but even a pinch gives a fantastic taste  and a wonderful colour  next separate three eggs put the yolks  into a mixing bowl  add dijon mustard  finely chopped garlic  the drained saffron  and a squeeze of lemon  then mix  whisking constantly add oil slowly it  won't take forever  for perfect flavor use half olive oil  and half vegetable oil  where the mayonnaise comes together  season  [Music]  a smooth thick consistency means it's  done  top with saffron